et là les vêtements qu'il faut
elle saura
parler avec empathie avec la
femme l'épouse du président au château
de Versailles dernier préparatif pour le
dîner royal dans la galerie des Glaces
la table de 62 mètres de long est en
train d'être dressé vers en cristal
porcelaine de Sèvres et autres dorures
dîner qui a provoqué quelques débats sur
la pertinence d'utiliser le château de
Versailles pour une réception
diplomatique l'Élysée dit qu'il s'agit
de faire rayonner la France à
l'international je voulais appeler ma
poularde Charles III
parce qu'il faut il faut attendre la
disparition et l'hommage officiel pour
pour nommer un plat attention il y a des
règles à suivre on ne
salue pas
entendre et c'est le roi qui pourtant la
ajouter une maîtresse appréciée
comme il faut dans la
mesure acérée la main du
roi et il a
mis son apprendra